bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition dans le cadre d'europe dans
cette émission nous irons tout d'abord à
vigo le plus grand port d'espagne qui
voit d'un très mauvais oeil la réforme
des quotas de pêche
ensuite direction la suède un des pays
qui a la législation la plus favorable
aux mineurs étrangers isolés
enfin nous irons en belgique à bruxelles
pays qui a légalisé l'euthanasie en 2002
mais d'abord on part en grèce épicentre
de la crise de la dette en europe
alors thomas pour nous la crise grecque
c'est un petit peu un feuilleton
quotidien dans nos journaux télévisés
les plans de sauvegarde se suivent se
ressemblent
et vous vous avez voulu aller à la
rencontre des grecs qui subissent ces
plans de rigueur successifs
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti sur
place mais mon sentiment c'est que cette
crise d'austérité s'abat sur ceux qui
n'ont pas les moyens d'en réchapper les
fonctionnaires les retraités et plus
généralement les classes moyennes et les
classes populaires
parallèlement il ya aussi ceux qui ont
de l'argent qui existent cela et qui
échappent un petit peu aux taxes car ils
menacent d'aller investir ailleurs
et cette injustice terrible explique je
pense la crise sociale qui est en train
de se dérouler là bas et les émeutes
qu'on a pu voir aussi dernièrement donc
on sera avec vous à athènes
à
et toi là vas-y film film notre ce
qu'endure le petit peuple montre sur
leur visage se lisent colère et
résignation
tous sont venus s'acquitter d'une taxe
exceptionnelle
je dois payer 360 euros et votre
retraite va suffire tant que j'ai assez
pour manger du pain éventuellement un
peu de fromage mon gars on n'aura plus
rien à manger une taxe adossés à leurs
factures d'électricité
s'il ne paye pas à temps la compagnie
leur coupera le courant cette mesure
injuste
on nous étrangle dit à sarkozy qui
l'aurait nous aider mieux que ça un
poids souvent insupportable pour une
population déjà très affaibli ils sont
fonctionnaires chômeurs salariés du
privé ou retraités nous sommes partis à
la rencontre de ces grecs frappés par la
crise
cette taxe exceptionnelle monsieur
constantine où il a reçu lui aussi pour
ses 145 m² il est dû payer de 1507
mais ce sont surtout ses revenus qui
l'inquiète
si la situation de cet ancien
ambassadeur n'est pas des plus
difficiles
elle est en revanche éloquente en 6 - sa
retraite a littéralement fondu passant
de 3700 à 2500 euros mensuels en grèce
les fonctionnaires sont les principales
cibles de l'austérité ils ont perdu
jusqu'à 30% de leurs revenus
sans compter que pendant ce temps là le
coût de la vie lui a augmenté le singe
l'alimentation l'alimentation monde
voulait remonter la tva annoncée 23%
alors tous les prix sont presque bout
d'un an à une perte de chacun 50 de
changer
amélie ça là bas mais l arabe a doté la
v6 acquis vers la mer giorgos lui est un
jeune interne en chirurgie ces derniers
temps il n'a pu que constater la
dégradation de ses conditions de travail
chaque jour il ya quelque chose soit
c'est du matériel qui manquent soit on
apprend qu'on va fermer
ou bien qu'on doit pas essayer
et puis le jour d'après on manque de
matériel enfin chaque jour où il ya
quelque chose de nouveau
l'hôpital demande désormais aux patients
de payer 5 euros de droits d'accès aux
soins est d'amener leurs propres
compresses stériles
en deux ans le budget des hôpitaux grecs
a baissé de plus de 40%
pour beaucoup de jeunes grecs le
sentiment d'appartenir à une génération
sacrifiée prédomine si certains sont
tentés d'émigrer vers l'australie
notamment d'autres s'ils refusent nous
retrouvons un groupe d'amis au pied de
l'acropole
tous ont la quarantaine autour de la
table il y as you go ce l'illustrateur
de livres pour enfants cela fait un an
qu'il n'a pas eu de nouvelles commandes
il ya aussi alexandre roos et sa femme
eva eux se considèrent comme des
privilégiés
même s'ils commencent à faire attention
moi je travaille dans une grande
multinationale où il n'y a pas eu encore
de gros licenciement n'est de baisses de
salaires
mais depuis deux mois on a fait un
tableau on retranscrit par nos dépenses
quand on évoque avec eux la sortie de la
grèce de l'euro
l'avis général y est plutôt favorable
regarde ça fait dix ans que la grèce est
dans le rond son économie a reculé
la grèce a perdu en stabilité la grèce
n'est pas autonome l'euro et l'union
européenne nous ont amenés à une impasse
face à la crise certains ont choisi le
retour à la terre
giorgos à cofidis était employé de
banque il y encore six mois
licencié il décide de quitter athènes et
s'installe sur l'île d'eubée sa terre
natale avec sa mère et ses tantes
il a monté un salon de thé et vend des
productions locales à base de fruits
qu'ils distribuent aussi en supérette
on ne sera pas riche mais on arrive à
vivre décemment avec plus de modération
avec 17 % de chômeurs de plus en plus de
grecs font ce choix du retour à la terre
comme un refuge face à la crise
thomas vous avez réalisé ce reportage en
décembre dernier qu'est ce qui a changé
depuis en grèce très clairement on a
franchi un pas de plus dans l'austérité
baisse du salaire minimum de 22%
diminution encore des pensions de
retraite suppression massive d'emplois
dans la fonction publique le
gouvernement va supprimer 15000 postes
et tout ça a des conséquences très
visible on voit de plus en plus de sdf
dans les rues d'athènes il ya une
multiplication des soupes populaires et
un autre phénomène qui est loin d'être
anecdotique c'est que de plus en plus
d'enfants tombe dans les pommes le matin
à l'école tout simplement parce qu'ils y
vont le ventre vide
il ya un autre chiffre qui fait encore
plus peur c'est que il ya une
augmentation de 20% de la consommation
d'héroïne en 2011
vous avez repris contact avec les
personnes qu'on a vu dans votre
reportage que sont ils devenus
vallat démosthène constantino par
exemple l'ancien ambassadeur à la
retraite vient de voir sa pension
diminuée de 400 euros le mois dernier
alors que déjà dans le reportage
il nous explique qu'elle a fondu de près
d'un tiers en l'espace d'un an les
giorgos le médecin qui travaille à
l'hôpital après de la place omonia
m'explique que les crédits de santé ont
encore diminué que ça à voir des ça va
avoir des conséquences catastrophiques
sur son travail au quotidien et enfin
eva la femme d'alexandre aux convois à
la fin du sujet elle a très peur de
faire partie de la vague de
licenciements des quinze mille
fonctionnaires
merci thomas autre crise qui touche
l'union européenne celle du secteur de
la pêche
la réforme de la politique des quotas
est prévue pour 2014 et déjà elle
inquiète
sandra cerqueira s'est rendu à vigo le
plus gros ports de pêches d'espagne
sandra la pêche illégale revient souvent
au coeur de l'actualité pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez choisi l'espagne pour
aller traiter cette question des ong des
associations écologistes qui ont révélé
que des armateurs espagnol avait été
condamné pour pêche illégale et que
malgré tout il continue à recevoir des
subventions et donc c'est en espagne à
vigo que s'est installée l' agence
communautaire de pêche qui est censé en
fait contrôler les inspections des
différents états membres de l'union
européenne
certains m'ont dit sur place qu'il
regrettait que cette agence
n'interviennent pas plus au quotidien et
certains m'ont même dit c'est une agence
qui est dans le fond ne sert qu'à
recevoir des rapports mais elle ne fait
rien de plus il est 5h30 du matin sous
la halle hanche à la grande halle aux
poissons de vigo la criée vient de
commencer
des inspecteurs de la gendarmerie
maritime sont là ils vérifient que la
marchandise est conforme aux normes
européennes et contrôler la provenance
des poissons et leur taille
chaque poisson doit mesurer minimum 20
cm
hélas en votes ça dépasse on est dans
une taille réglementaire ils sont 17 à
se relayer
c'est bien peu pour contrôler les deux
mille tonnes de poissons qui arrivent
chaque jour
s'il ya infraction on donne une amende
mais il faut un procès pour retirer le
permis de pêche fait ce qu'on peut on
fait vraiment comme on peut
des vendeurs qui s'étonnerait presque de
les voir est-ce qu'ils viennent tous les
jours faire le contrôle dans parfois on
voit les vétérinaires au film mais eux
ils viennent rarement et dès le
lendemain la décharge des bateaux se
fait sans le moindre contrôle
aucune vérification des quotas de la
licence de pêche de la provenance des
cargaisons interdiction de filmer de
plus près 100 inspecteurs il n'est plus
possible de tourner la caméra dérange
sur le plus grand port de pêche d'europe
un tel manque de contrôle peut
surprendre
neuf cent cinquante mille tonnes de
poissons ont transité par viggo l'an
passé un record
la plus grande flotte celles qui
touchent aussi le plus de subventions de
lieux plus d'un milliard d'euros ces
cinq dernières années
il dispose de beaucoup de nouvelles
technologies ces bateaux oui on est
justement en train d'installer un
nouveau radar beaucoup plus moderne
ce sont les aides de bruxelles qui ont
aidé à moderniser les chalutiers
celui ci comporte un gps une plate forme
satellitaire et même des sonars qui
traquent sans marge d'erreur les bancs
de poissons et à l'extérieur des filets
de pêche de plusieurs centaines de
mètres
les quotas attribués par l'union
européenne ont été gelés et le problème
de notre flotte en galice c'est qu'elle
ne dispose pas de quota suffisant pour
que notre activité soit la plus rentable
possible alors nous sommes obligés pour
continuer à travailler d'acheter les
droits de pêche d'autres pays
exemple avec ce bateau son quota a été
atteint et pour continuer à l'utiliser
son propriétaire espagnol a racheté les
droits de pêche d'une entreprise
française rien interdit cette pratique
mais elle peut parfois frôlé l
illégalité
l'union européenne a déjà épinglé
l'espagne pour sa surpêche
d'après cet écologiste certaines
sociétés de galice ont même été condamné
pour pêche illégale tout en continuant
pourtant à recevoir des aides et sauce
est temps que les fonds européens seront
en partie distribué aux entreprises par
l'intermédiaire des régions autonomes il
en sera ainsi
en galice le secteur de la pêche est
plus puissant que tout sa capacité
d'influencé politique est énorme
ce qui explique que les autorités
espagnoles les sphères et ferme les yeux
le pib de la pêche en galice et 25 fois
supérieur à la moyenne européenne
le solde sur le port c'est un lobby
considérable bruxelles a très peu de
pouvoirs pour infléchir efficacement la
politique des états neuf espèces sur dix
sont selon lui surexploiter les poissons
commencent à manquer alors les bateaux
européens pêche de plus en plus dans les
eaux africaines
où les infractions sont nombreuses
pour clemente la politique commune de la
pêche est en panne
elle continue de favoriser les intérêts
économiques de quelques entreprises
la flotte industrielle ne s'arrête
jamais elle peut pêcher n'importe où là
où il n'y a pas de normes sanitaires de
quotas c'est trop de concurrence pour
nous ici on est obligé de respecter des
règles strictes le doyen des pêcheurs
fulmine contre bruxelles et sa réforme
qui veut créer un marché des quotas
permettant de les échanger et de les
vendre
la pêche artisanale est moribonde il ya
de moins en moins d'emplois et avec la
réforme
combien vont encore disparaître joie il
en est sûr
si demain les quotas peuvent se monnayer
le marché de la pêche profitera encore
plus aux industriels sandra on voit bien
la fin de votre reportage on sent
énormément d'inquiétude chez ces petits
pêcheurs oui ils s'inquiètent de voir
leur situation empirer si la réforme de
la politique commune de la pêche et donc
voter en 2014 comme prévu car lieu pour
protéger les ressources maritimes
comptent diminuer le nombre de bateaux
en mettant en place un marché des quotas
de pêche et donc chaque entreprise de
pêche pourra acheter ou vendre ses
quotas à un armateur de son pays ou un
armateur d'un autre pays européen
et il faut dire que dans les pays où ce
marché des quotas a été mis en place
comme au danemark
cela aboutit à une concentration donc du
marché entre les mains de quelques
armateurs au détriment de la pêche
artisanale et le problème de ces
industriels c'est qu'en plus il ya de la
surpêche donc à force d'épuiser les
ressources ont fini par aller pêcher
aussi à l'étranger et notamment en
afrique
oui c'est ça en théorie les zones de
pêche appartenant ont donc aux pays
africains sont régies par le droit
international mais en réalité les eaux
africaines sont exploités par l'union
européenne qui va donc pêché dans les
eaux africaines et c'est un manque à
gagner terrer pour ces pays près d'un
milliard d'euros par an est aussi le
résultat c'est que c'est des emplois de
pêcheurs qui sont menacés et la mise en
péril aussi de la sécurité alimentaire
de ces pays qu'il faut dire sont des
pays pauvres
merci sandra malgré ces crises l'europe
représentent un eldorado pour bon nombre
d'étrangers certains viennent y chercher
du travail
d'autres fuient la guerre parmi eux
beaucoup sont encore des enfants on les
appelle les mineurs étrangers is
les et seibert en jardin glace qui nous
en parle bérengère c'est un problème qui
est assez méconnu est ce qu on sait
combien d'enfants sont concernés et d'où
vient-il
selon les associations on estime en
france qu ils seraient environ 5 6
milles au niveau européen selon le hcr
il ya des estimations qui varie entre 50
à 100 milles
une seule chose qui est certaine c'est
que leur nombre augmente tous les ans
quant aux pays d'origine s'est longtemps
et l afghanistan mais c'est une
situation qui évolue en fonction de
l'actualité mondiale en 2010 par exemple
en france on a remarqué qu'il y avait
beaucoup de jeunes qui venaient du sri
lanka du bangladesh mais aussi d'afrique
des pays du maghreb en particulier une
des conséquences des révolutions arabes
bien sûr bien entendu donc on vous suit
en suède à la rencontre de tawab et ali
partie seule d'afghanistan c'est après
trois mois d'un voyage nous est
difficile cali arrive en europe il ya un
an et demi
il n'a alors que 16 ans est à l'essai
toute sa famille sur place
c'est un peu par hasard qu'il débarque
en suède
j'avais pas spécialement pour ces venir
en europe
je vais fait par nécessité comme tout le
monde j'ai quitté l'afghanistan à cause
de la guerre parce que la situation
était trop difficile là bas
à son arrivée ali est orienté vers un
centre de transit
après quelques semaines on le conduit
ici a eu plein de sb environ 35
kilomètres de stockholm
quand on arrive ici on sait rien ne
connaît pas la loi ne connaît pas les
gens on comprend pas comment les choses
marchent à ce difficile
ici comme ali ou tawab la plupart des
jeunes viennent d'afghanistan
les autres sont originaires d'irak ou
d'ex urss
en tout ils sont une vingtaine âgés de
16 à 19 ans à être hébergés dans cette
maison d'accueil jusqu'à leur majorité
pour que je puisse venir non père a
vendu tous ses champs le voyage au total
a duré pendant huit jours
mon père avait tout préparé les contacts
nécessaires l'avion que je devais
prendre mais évidemment toute ma famille
me manque beaucoup
dès leur arrivée les mineurs font une
demande d'asile et ils sont alors placés
sous la responsabilité d'un tuteur
bénévoles qui les accompagne jusqu'à
leur 18 ans comme la plupart des jeunes
afghans trois mois après sa demande
d'asile tawab a obtenu le droit de
rester définitivement en suède
c'était vraiment un grand soulagement
que d'obtenir ce permis de séjour parce
que j'avais peur d'être renvoyés dans
mon pays
plus de 2700 migrants mineurs sont
arrivés en suède l'an dernier un nombre
en constante augmentation
à l'issue de leur demande d'asile plus
de 83% d'entre eux obtiennent le droit
de rester définitivement
en revanche ceux qui n'ont pas de permis
de séjour sont théoriquement renvoyés
chez eux
voyez parfois les parents ne veulent pas
de nom pas de contact mais il n'y a que
20 30 40 peut-être 54,5 et quand on
retrouve les parents et en allemagne
elle peut être réunis dans leur pays
d'origine en 2011 72 jeunes ont ainsi
été renvoyés dans leur pays d'origine
pas suffisant pour le gouvernement
suédois puisque avec d'autres pays
européens
il travaille actuellement à la création
d'orpheline en irak ou en afghanistan
une politique qui inquiète les
associations je manquais qu'on va forcer
alemana contraire
au pays sans vérifier ainsi que la
sécurité que la famille un mas prend
soin de ses enfants encore et il faut
que le retour est dans l'intérêt des
dents voire héberger jusqu'à leur
majorité
les jeunes sont aussi scolarisés
lorsqu'ils arrivent ils sont dans un
premier tour regroupés dans des classes
spécifiques pour apprendre le suédois
après ils rejoignent des classes
classiques dans cette école des lycéens
suédois propose aux migrants de les
aider dans leurs devoirs quelques heures
par semaine on trouve que c'est une très
bonne idée car beaucoup de jeunes ont
beaucoup de mal à faire leur devoir ils
ne pouvons pas recevoir des dans la
maison donc c'est bien de recevoir plein
à l'école la langue suédoise paul et
peter la maîtrise maintenant
parfaitement
pourtant lorsqu'ils sont arrivés dira
qu'il y ait cinq ans fuyant les
persécutions
ces deux jeunes chrétiens ne parler que
l'arabe en suède
le regroupement familial est primordial
aussi au bout de trois ans les jumeaux
ont réussi à faire venir leurs familles
ma famille est ici maintenant j'ai mon
père ma mère mon frère certaines de mes
soeurs tout le monde est content un
travail d'autres étudient
c'est une nouvelle vie un nouvel
environnement je pense que c'est bien
que nous nous soyons installés ici quand
tu te sens bien et est en sécurité
quelque part tu peux faire des projets
pour le futur
âgé de 21 ans leader veut devenir
médecin
son frère dentiste leur vie c'est en
suède qu'il imagine désormais ils
attendent maintenant d'obtenir la
nationalité suédoise
bérengère on le voit bien dans notre
reportage certains enfants ne sont pas
régularisés et sont donc reconduits
est ce qu'on sait où ils vont pour
l'instant l'afghanistan n'ont fait pas
partie ça peut être vers des pays
africains ou vers des pays de l'ex urss
comme le kazakhstan ou l'ouzbékistan par
exemple mais il ya une deuxième
procédure qui existent au niveau
européen et qui applique la suède est
pratiquement tous les pays européens
appliquent sauf la france c'est le
règlement dublin ii selon lequel les
dossiers des migrants doivent être
traités dans le premier pays européen
dans lequel il arrive c'est des
procédures qui inquiète beaucoup les
jeunes donc certains préfèrent fuir
en suède on les appelle les enfants
cachés sans concernerait environ cinq à
six cents enfants et là il ya un vrai
risque que dénoncent les associations
bien sûr et en français ce qu'on sait
comment ça se passe jusqu'à l'âge de 18
ans et du fait leurs minorités les
migrants sont hébergés soigner tout
change à l'âge de 18 ans pour avoir le
droit de rester en fond s'il avait
entamé une procédure est à 18 ans ils
deviennent sans papiers ils deviennent
son papier donc ils entament des
procédures
alors là il n'y a pas vraiment cette
eastick le seul chiffre dont on dispose
c'est celui de la demande de droit
d'asile en 2010 et environ 600 demandes
qui ont été effectuées 40% qui ont été
favorables mais la plupart ne sont pas
concernés par ce par le statut de
réfugié ils obtiennent alors soit une
autorisation de séjour temporaire ça
peut être un an ça peut être dix ans il
y en a certains mêmes qui sont renvoyés
alors qu'ils vivent en france depuis
trois quatre ans qu'ils ont appris la
langue donc là c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué
merci bérengère en france la question de
l'euthanasie n'en finit plus de susciter
des polémiques pourtant en europe
plusieurs pays l'ont légalisé
c'est le cas de la belgique direction
bruxelles avec flora sauvage
flora quels sont les pays qui ont
légalisé l'euthanasie en europe alors en
europe on a les pays bas le luxembourg
la belgique en belgique ça fait déjà 10
ans que qu'ils ont légalisé l'euthanasie
et puis il ya également la suisse alors
la suisse ils ont ce qu'on appelle le
suicide assisté
et quelle est la différence là la
différence entre l'euthanasie et le
suicide assisté c'est que l'euthanasie
c'est une mort demandé par le patient
mais induite par un tiers en général un
médecin alors que le suicide assisté
c'est le patient lui même qui va se
donner la mort donc là on vous suit à
bruxelles clinique saint pierre à
ottignies à 30 km de bruxelles
ici on pratique des hautes analyse
depuis 2002 date de la dépénalisation
plus de 4000 l'euthanasie ont été
réalisées en belgique
comment ça va ce patient a 85 ans suivi
depuis des années pour insuffisance
rénale par le docteur vautier il souffre
aujourd'hui d'un cancer de la peau c'est
clair j'ai demandé le 3 et pour mango
fera celui de denain poche je ne sert
plus à rien sa pensée je vous fait qu on
est là pour fait pour vous soutenir
jusqu'au bout 1
il faut dire que ce soit pas un état
dépressif et c'est ici qu'on a demandé
l'avis de nos confrères psychiatres qui
l'ont longuement vue et qui ont confirmé
qu'ils n'étaient pas du tout dépressif
mais que c'était mûrement réfléchi on
fait l'araignée aussi il peut plus laver
tout seul il est dépendant comme
quelqu'un de 85 ans qui a une longue
histoire insuffisance rénale et non de
ce qu'on l'aide à mourir dignement
mais ça ça en fait qui appelle tout le
monde ça veut dire que si on on l'essaie
il ya plein de personnes âgées qui
souhaitent leur vie les gens veulent pas
être une charge pour leur famille ou
leur entourage et qui n'arrivent pas à
mourir et qu'il demande
oui voilà là on vous réserve on n'a pas
d'autre solution allait proposer
acceptable pour un patient pour faire un
dessin agréable et facile et que
refusent les autres solutions comme de
rentrer études et puis dans l'univers ou
voilà pour moi cet acte de pousser
pousser une seringue reste à un acte
très difficile
ce que parce que ça va tout à fait qu
être mais ma conviction personnelle de
chrétiens engagés
ça reste difficile au bout d'un mois
d'observation le personnel médical va
finalement accédé à sa demande après
s'être assuré qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
solution pour le soulager je sais rien
lui proposer d'autre que ça et je vais
cheminer avec lui et est alors les
patients sont tellement infiniment
remerciant que que c'est un moment
d'intense humanité c'est pas du tout un
moment violent au sens c'est pas un
moment dur quoi c'est un moment doux 80
est anase y sont pratiqués chaque mois
en belgique d ôta nazis qui sont
enregistrés auprès de la commission
fédérale de contrôle et d'évaluation
marque anglaise est l'un des huit
membres de cette instance qui examine
les déclarations de ténèbres de je
regarde si le médecin a bien respecté
les conditions de la loi
il ya trois conditions essentielles
la première c'est la demande du patient
claire volonté répétée sans pression
extérieure
la deuxième celle existant d'une maladie
incurable grave et la troisième c'est la
présente souffrances insupportables
en belgique la moitié des états nazis
sont pratiqués à l'hôpital
l'autre moitié se fait à domicile par
l'intermédiaire du médecin traitant
à 54 ans cet homme souffre d'un cancer
de la gorge
il a été opéré à plusieurs reprises mais
sans succès d'un grand engagement pour
mon chapeau à voilette parti
ce patient est ici pour formaliser sa
demande d'euthanasie comme le prévoit la
loi belge
il faut l'avis d'un deuxième médecin
indépendant qui ne connaît pas le
patient on doit soulager avant tout le
patient il faut faire passer davantage
la survie ou non du patient avant cet
hymne à la souffrance elle est encore
pour le moment tolérable mais jusque
quand et c'est monsieur qui a fixé sa
propre limite en termes de tolérance
vis-à-vis de cette souffrance
nous n'avons pas encore fixé toute hâte
c'est à dire que tant que seul jeu
vivement conseillé
c'est demain mais le patient est au
centre du dispositif
ce n'est pas la société qui décide ce
qui est bon ce qui est mauvais pour mon
patient c'est mon patient qui décide
comment est-ce qu'il veut s'en aller
en france l'association pour le droit à
mourir dans la dignité milite pour
légaliser l'euthanasie
d'après un sondage ipsos 94% des
français serait favorable à une
dépénalisation pour les patients
atteints de maladies incurables
flora contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
penser l'euthanasie ne semble pas
concerner beaucoup de gens est ce qu'on
a des chiffres
alors oui on a des chiffres en fait
effectivement contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait penser il n'y a pas de hausses
spectaculaires en belgique concernant
l'euthanasie ya une nette augmentation
régulière l'an dernier il ya eu un
millier de personnes qui ont été
euthanasiés en belgique c'est à dire une
hausse de 16% par rapport à l'année 2010
c'est une augmentation qui s'explique en
fait par le fait que l'euthanasie n'est
plus tabou aujourd'hui en belgique
peut-être aussi par le fait que les
patients connaissent mieux leurs droits
peuvent demander l'euthanasie quand ils
arrivent en fin de vie et flora en
france comment ça marche
alors en france la mort est encadré par
deux lois votées en 2002 la loi sur le
droit des patients et la loi leonetti
l'idée globale en france et on interdit
l'euthanasie on développe les soins
palliatifs et on essaye de limiter
l'acharnement thérapeutique et les soins
palliatifs la france est quand même
assez en retard
c'est un argument que met en avant les
partisans de l'euthanasie en france
c'est de dire mais selon la développer
les soins palliatifs il y aura peut-être
plus besoin de l'euthanasie aujourd'hui
les soins palliatifs sont assez en
retard par rapport à d'autres pays
notamment les pays du nord de l'europe
un merci flora voilà en quête d'europe
c'est fini on se retrouve très vite sur
public sénat et tous les jours sur
publicsenat.fr